- He either has to be Billy Dee's son
or they went to a new
planet, Planet Negroxe
or something that they just
found a bunch of brothers.
- Super excited that
black guy is a main character.
- He's black, I'm black!
To see a black guy holding
a lightsaber is crazy.
- A black Stormtrooper and I'm just like,
man, George Lucas' wife is black.
- There's a black guy as a main character,
so he's got a lightsaber,
oh he's going to be a Jedi.
- I gotta say I'm pretty excited,
very stiff nipples. Cut ice.
- I'd have gave him a line up though.
- Oh my god.
- My kids can play with
this, and I'd be like
yeah you know, cough it up.
- This is so sick.
- I like Luke, Anakin was pretty badass,
but this is a black guy
fucking shit up. Can I curse?
- My name's Finn and I'm in charge now.
- That name is kinda weak though, Finn.
- I don't know what to do.
- Dilemma, black man.
- Representation is everything in film.
- Really awesome whenever
I see a different race,
or some different
diversity in a Sci-Fi film.
- It's nonexistent, which kind of sucks.
I mean Lord of the Rings
didn't have any black people.
I mean maybe the Orcs
but that's fucked up.
The Orcs stole my bike
in the fourth grade.
- They've had black dudes
in Star Wars for a while,
but never as the main characters.
James Earl Jones, Billy
Dee, Samuel L. Jackson.
- Second most powerful
Jedi on the Jedi Order.
- Now my man John.
- If you think about Princess
Leia in the first trilogy,
women attached themselves
to Princess Leia.
- If you're not going
to have any black people
in like future films,
you're basically saying
there's not going to be any
black people in the future.
- Maybe next time they'll
have a homosexual Jedi.
- He got a line up in the toy though.
(blaster shoots)
(chuckles)
- I've had a pretty messed up day.
- I can relate, can you?
I know you can
(laughs wheezily)
- I am so excited for this
thing, I should buy a ticket.
- [Voiceover] They should have
bigger brothers in Star Wars.
How tall is Billy Dee Williams?
- I'm taking this.
(chuckles)